comme chaque soir depuis samedi dernier
on prend à présent la direction de la
porte de versailles à paris vous le
savez le salon de l'agriculture
c'est aussi l'occasion pour les régions
de présenter leurs spécialités
culinaires
on en parle ce soir avec antoine verner
en direct du salon
antoine vous êtes près de la boutique du
centre val de loire
oui sur le stand même de la boutique
centre val de loire alors ici que des
produits régionaux estampillé 100 %
centre val de loire et je suis avec karl
galmiche vous gérer cette boutique ici
au salon de l'agriculture quelques
quelques exemples de ces produits
régionaux de ses spécialités régionales
et bien effectivement donc vous avez sur
votre droite
les produits salés et puis
progressivement on se décale vers les
produits qui sont sucrés avec d'abord
les chiffres les belles siens qui
viennent de beauce vous avez les
produits salés 2d châble et qu'ils
viennent du loir-et-cher des terrines
les terrines de loire mais chez parti
devant nous et sa femme julie vous avez
37 saveurs donc une sélection d'à peu
près 5 terrine de port en port de
touraine pour rose de touraine les ports
qui viennent du 28 la cochonnaille de
des aubois ensuite des condiments vous
avez la moutarde ainsi que la mayonnaise
à la truite réalisé par arthur et lola
qui sont aussi les réalisateurs du
leonardo dont on parle beaucoup sur le
salon vous avez ensuite le travail de
marie thé laluque qui était présente
avec nous aujourd'hui vous avez les
produits promogim donc les vergers dame
ans avec notamment leur dernière version
pomme framboise qui est un vrai succès
et ensuite vous retrouvez donc les
boissons pétillantes qui viennent du 28
de janville avec notamment cette boisson
la la limonade à 130 ans voilà la
beauceronne l'incontournable vous
retrouvez ensuite du sucré avec les
miels ligne aile de cour cheverny et
puis le miel de monsieur oiseaux ici son
miel d'acacia et ses miels de ronces on
a également un produit qui est assez
innovant qui vient du 37 qui s'appelle
donc confiture de lait sous chèvres et
donc voilà c'est assez intéressant et
notamment le ressenti des gens va qui
ont fait goûter c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment super c'est quoi ces poils
ressenti des gens qu est ce qu ils
veulent qu est-ce qui cherchent ici
c'est quoi le produit phare alors
ce que les gens cherchent effectivement
découvrir la région et donc on essaie de
se faire les ambassadeurs de la région
ils aiment goûter ils aiment qu'on leur
explique ils aiment qu'on leur vend des
produits bien sûr et quand ils viennent
à notre stand quand ils viennent sur la
région c'est vrai qu'ils cherchent un
produit notamment
voilà on va le voir on veut croire je
prendre en main c'est ça voilà la poire
d'olive et comme par hasard comme par
hasard
et la question qui revient très
fréquemment c'est évidemment comment le
fruit se trouve-t-il à l'intérieur la
réponse
la réponse est bien il suffit de
regarder sur le stand de la région où
vous voyez en fait une photo ou la
bouteille est plongé comme ceci avec la
branche à l'intérieur est le fruit qui
est en train de se développer
le fruit pouces dedans est exactement la
bouteille est attaché dans l'arbre tout
à fait et puis ensuite on met le d'ici
là le fruit du d'ici là et donc le plus
de la récolte des poires qui ont été
distillées par seule écoute et on va on
va découvrir quelques produits régionaux
encore deux produits régionaux je vous
propose de voir ce reportage pour la
réaliser cet après midi avec marion ptac
un camembert spécialité du cher
surprenant sa composition
loin de la tradition normande le
berrichon c'est un praliné amandes
noisettes enrobage chocolat noir une
longue histoire pour en arriver là qui
sort la remonte à mon arrière grand père
qui était boulanger pâtissier en région
centre dans une petite boulangerie un
petit village de 500 habitants au départ
créer des recettes de biscuits dans
cette première recette de biscuits qui
marchait très bien dans la région centre
et le croquer du berry et du croc est
née l'insolite berrichon succès garanti
c'est délicieux
moi j'aime beaucoup le côté croustillant
de la crypte est en phase autres
douceurs spécialités régionales
l'authentic le pithiviers
c'est un 4/4 aux amendes sans farine 1/4
d'amande un quart de sucre un quart
d'heure et un quart d'heure et la
décoration c'est de la glace à royal
la soeur royal c'est à dire blanc d'oeuf
avec sucre glace il existe le pithiviers
feuilleter le plus connu mais ici on
travaille le vrai le plus ancien xviie
siècle juste après la renaissance
période à l'honneur sur le stand centre
val de loire
karl finalement notre région elle est
truffée de spécialités est tout à fait
et là on a la chance effectivement
devoir représenter 24 producteurs de la
donc de la région qui sont estampillés
c'est du centre mais au delà de ça c'est
plus de 200 producteurs qui sont
vraiment sur le territoire et au c'est
une chance et olemps ici faire découvrir
80 de nos plus beaux produits
merci beaucoup karl nous on se retrouve
demain à midi et demain soir pour de
nouveaux reportages et de nouveaux
direct demain